wake up yeah wake up ask hey everybody
it's Charlie we got to freak out about
this episode of Walking Dead there's so
much stuff that they dumped on here
because they dropped a couple teasers
for the whispers which are coming up
they want to let you know all the big
stuff that they're doing like please
don't bail on the show and they
announced special plans for Rick Grimes
Walking Dead movies that will spin off
Rick Grimes story that I'll explain at
the end of the video but we'll talk
about the episode Easter eggs first
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
starting with top 10 WTF at Easter eggs
number 10 the trippy flashback intro to
the hospital bed from the pilot episode
so the funny thing that did with this
episode is that they started and ended
on a similar type moment with Rick in
the pilot in that hospital bed you start
out with him literally in that room when
he's hallucinating himself twin peak
style we're like the Rick and the bed
starts talking to him then his very last
scene is him waking up in a hospital bed
albeit on a helicopter flying away the
flashbacks in general were mainly just
to put his story into context like where
have they been what has he done what
does it meant where is he leaving things
what will it be like after he's gone the
title of the episode what comes after is
a very apt metaphor for the show in real
life like how are they gonna go on
without the Rick Grimes character or
Andrew Lincoln number 9 you may have
spotted this easter-egg Night of the
Living Dead cabin the owner of the cabin
that he runs up on is called cardille
that's the name of someone from the
George Romero Night of the Living Dead
series and also I think a character from
Day of the Dead as well but you may have
noticed as he started a flashback at
each of the different places it almost
reminded you of different places
locations that the show has been in
previous seasons you started in the
hospital you go to a cabin that looks
suspiciously like Daryl's cabin the
number 8
welcome back Shane and you go to the
site of Rick's initial accident and the
pilot that put him in the hospital bed
to begin with so we all knew that Shane
was coming back for a cameo this season
and as we got closer and they announced
Andrew Lincoln was leaving the show I
was like yeah BAM he is probably coming
back to send Andrew Lincoln out for some
Shane Rick moment so I feel like Jon
Bernthal did a great job he was probably
my favorite person to come back
because I really like Jon Bernthal he
was the Punisher before he was ever the
Punisher in their whole conversation is
about trying to get Rick to acknowledge
that they're really on the knows about
it you need to be like me in order to
see this through he has to become the
hardcore version of Rick if he's gonna
survive and make it out of this
situation they laugh and joke like
everything's water under the bridge
everything they've been through even the
fact that Rick ended up killing Shane in
that field in the way they do this
transition is also really cool too when
they come back to real life because they
make like Shane is going to bite him as
he just wakes up in the walkers right in
his face but you can kind of tell how
they're just trying to reconcile
everything that he's done how hardcore
he got the choices that he made in fact
there were a couple points in the
episode where people were making fun of
Rick for the choices he made he should
have done it this way he should have
done it the Shane way then you have the
genuine hallucination of Shane telling
him the exact same thing you need to do
this the way that I would do it
otherwise you're gonna die 7 Maggie
comes to kill negan and they play it
that way for most of the scene that they
have until she steps in and he starts
taunting her and you find out what's
really going on like he kind of senses
what's coming he knows that she's
probably gonna try and I felt like the
way that Jeffrey Dean Morgan played it
was actually really good the turn like
because he goes from what you would
expect from negan like just taunting it
out of her like he's got some trick up
his sleeve he's gonna try and escape or
something like that but the beautiful
turn that he has in their moment there
when he steps into the light number 6
negan has become The Golem version of
negan please please you have to do it I
can't live like this I want to be with
my wife I want to be with Lucille he's
just this crumbling shell of a man so
that's how they justify her not killing
him because he's suffering a fate worse
than death right now and he even kind of
slinks back into his cell of his own
accord he doesn't even put up a fight so
that was the moment where I was like oh
they're definitely playing this
authentically and negan really has
broken so this will be important when I
talk about the teaser for the next
couple of episodes because you have the
older version of Judith and you have
negan talking to her like she has some
kind of relationship with him like she
goes to visit him every once in a while
and he doesn't seem quite so broken
anymore and we have the whispers coming
up like there was a big whispers teaser
so I think this is all of them doing
negan comic book storyline but
circle back around for that because
number five welcome back Herschel and
Hershel's farm so this is just another
one of those moments where Herschel is
trying to tell Rick that he did a good
job you don't need to worry about
everyone else and again Rick tries to
atone for the things that he's done the
people that he's lost he feels like he
hasn't done enough Herschel's just
trying to tell him no no no you're good
dude so just another big location on the
show that they're traveling through in
these flashbacks in another big person
to come back in film scenes because a
little while after this was filmed the
actor in real life passed away all the
cast members were posting their
memorials they had a special message
about him after one of the previous
episodes it was really sad to see him go
but it was cool that he was able to film
this scene before he passed away
number four next big flashback welcome
back Sasha on top of the pile of bodies
if you guys didn't spot it this is
actually Greg Nicotero in the pile here
he does most of the effects for The
Walking Dead now he's become a producer
he directs some of the episodes he's a
much bigger part of the show than he was
initially but usually when there's
really cool Walker's and special effects
he's the person behind all that stuff
the speech Sasha gave to him was a
slightly different version of the
speeches that he got in all the other
flashbacks but the funny thing this is
kind of foreshadowing the end of the
episode is that she talked about things
not dying the group will live on is this
great cycle that's more of a message to
the fans like we're gonna continue the
show things will go on the cycle of life
old actors go away new actors come in
the story continues the survivors as a
group will continue but it also works in
a literal context too because he flew
away in the helicopter admittedly
looking like he was not going to die the
Sasha flashback at the campsite reminded
me of the campsite from way back in
early season when when the group was
first together three rick blows at the
bridge famous last words
i found him meant to pay off the
recurring theme going all the way back
to season 1 when he says i need to find
my family because that's how he started
out in season 1 I'm just looking for my
family I need to find him then obviously
eventually he found them and they just
happened to be with Shane they even
joked about that too aren't you looking
for my family Rick how's my baby Judith
doing I look how on the nose they were
with the way they acknowledge Judith as
Shane's daughter too Jada's saves Rick
with this mysterious helicopter group
she keeps referring to A's and B's so
there were a couple separate teasers and
there's a couple
groups that they're introducing from the
comics initially I thought they were
just trying to tease the whispers but
the actual whisperers teaser in those
flash-forwards were a little bit
different so the helicopter people might
be Commonwealth that they're teasing
because they seem a little bit more
organized than the whispers are which
you know a very hardcore group but they
don't have quite the resources that the
Commonwealth does but it's just their
way of showing you that Rick Grimes will
be alive in the future his story will
continue in Walking Dead movies so
deadline just broke the news that Andrew
Lincoln signed a deal to star in Walking
Dead movies that the AMC has planned
saying that they will continue Rick
Grimes story meaning it sounds like
it'll be happening in the future after
this moment they won't start filming
till next year we don't know what the
story is going to be in how they will
invoke any of the stuff happening on the
main show because you know number one
big flash-forward we get the Judith
flash forward in Magnus group from the
comics so I'm guessing that this is
maybe five six years in the future she's
about the same age as Carl was when he
first started wielding a gun in the
early seasons he started wearing Rick's
hat Magnus group shows up around the
time you meet the whispers in the comics
you see in the flash-forwards that
everybody has either a gray hair or they
just look a little bit older we haven't
seen negan in the light either but I'm
guessing that they probably color his
hair a little bit gray or too part of
the reason why they show you footage
from the next three episodes is because
that's the rest of the episodes for the
first half of the season and they want
to let you know all the big stuff they
have coming like please don't bail on
our show please keep watching we have
big stuff coming the moment where you
hear these two run into the ditch cover
themselves up with dirt you hear the
herd walk by but you hear these raspy
voices say where did they go as if the
walkers are speaking if you're not
familiar with the comics walkers do not
speak it's because the whispers are
wearing Walker skins to camouflage
themselves without being detected by the
other actual walkers so everybody let me
know what was your favorite WTF moment
from the episode and what do you think
about how they sent Andrew Lincoln out
it was definitely misleading with the
way they played it like we're gonna keep
him alive but he's not gonna be on the
show and I'll have this other spin-off
story that might not have anything to do
with what's happening on the main show
so if you're not really continuing to
watch The Walking Dead TV show you will
be able
go see the movie and check in on it
every once in a while but it'll be
curious to see what they do with the
whispers on the show because they're
like the next really big group there's a
whole bunch of other stuff coming up
between Marvel DC Game of Thrones
everything else leave your video
requests in the comments below there was
this funny video where Andrew Lincoln
talks about how he wanted to go off the
show click here to watch him prophesy
his own death here it's pretty funny and
click here for that new Game of Thrones
season 8 preview thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight